[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne
gellineck guten Abend es ist schwer zu
beurteilen ob das was die israelische
Armee gerade im Norden von Gaza macht
schon Teil der angekündigten
Bodenoffensive ist oder nicht offenbar
sind erste militärische spättrups der
Israelis in Gaza unterwegs am Abend kam
die Meldung dass diese Leichen von
verschleppten Geiseln entdeckt haben
gleichzeitig versucht sich ztausende von
palästinensischen Bewohnern aus dem
Norden des Gazastreifens in den Süden zu
retten während die hamasfunktionäre sich
in ihren unterirdischen Bunkern
verkrchen und Deutschland setzt nun doch
die Luftwaffe ein um in Israel
gestrandete Bundesbürger zurückzuholen l
walpot berichtet aus Tel Aviv
hananunis im südlichen Gasastreifen sie
haben die Flucht aus gazastadt geschafft
erschöpft in banger Erwartung dessen was
noch auf sie zukommt beri an der Grenze
zu Gaza er entscheidet wann Israels
Armee vorrücken wird Regierungschef
Netanyahu beim Truppenbesuch in dem
kibutz in dem hamasterroristen dutzende
Zivilisten brutal ermordeten und
verschleppten seine Truppen sind bereit
der Aufmarsch
abgeschlossen wir stehen im Süden Norden
im Zentrum rund um Gaza vorbereitet für
jeden Auftrag den wir
erhalten zu den Aufträgen gehören
anhaltende Luftangriffe auf hamasziele
in chanunis wurde heute ein
dreistöckiges Gebäude zerstört
Hilflosigkeit und Entsetzen bei den
Menschen wir hörten im Schlaf eine
gewaltige Explosion unser Haus wurde nur
am Rande getroffen aber das Nebenhaus
komplett ausgebomt unter den Trümmern
liegen doch
Opfer und es ist erst der Anfang der
Vergeltung das hat Israels
Regierungschef angekündigt die Frist für
die Bewohner sich in den Süden zu
begeben ist am Nachmittag abgelaufen
ztausende auf der Flucht es gibt kaum
Unterkünfte Lebensmittel oder Strom
erinnerungen werden wach an die nackbar
die Katastrophe der Vertreibung im Krieg
von
1948 das war unglaublich schwierig man
kann sich das nicht vorstellen wir
mussten zu Fuß es gab kein Auto mehr
überall
Raketen die Kinder sind müde wir haben
keine Windeln kein Essen kein Wasser
keine Toiletten es ist sehr
schwer
die Vereinten Nationen fordern dringend
die Einrichtung eines humanitären
Korridors darüber beriet Außenministerin
bärbock in Ciro mit ihrem ägyptischen
Kollegen schukri zugleich appellierte
sie noch einmal an die Hamas die Geiseln
darunter acht deutsche
freizulassen in Ägypten werden bereits
Hilfslieferungen für die notleidenden
Palästinenser vorbereitet die Grenze
bleibt aber vorerst geschlossen Gaza
gehöre den Palästinensern so die
offizielle Begründung ein anderer Grund
dürfte Kairos Furcht davor sein dass
einsiernde hamasterroristen auch Ägypten
destabilisieren könnten wenig Hoffnung
also für die Menschen in Gaza der Mann
der das alles zu verantworten hat
hamaschef han meldet sich unterdessen
aus dem sicheren Exil mit schwülztigen
Durchhalteparolen ich begrüße Ägyptens
Haltung auch wir wollen unsere Heimat
nicht verlassen wir bleiben in
Gaza mit wir meint er weniger sich
selbst als die Menschen die für hamaso
scheint es nur ein fand im fanatischen
terrorkampf
sind und aus netiwot in Israel ist uns
jetzt unser Korrespondent Michael
bberunge zugeschaltet guten Abend
Michael sie waren heute an der Grenze
zum Gazastreifen was konnten sie dort
beobachten wie unmittelbar steht eine
israelische Bodenoffensive
bevor wir waren heute Nachmittag in
quarasa das ist so nah am Gasastreifen
wie man dem Moment als Zivilist kommen
kann dort wo vor genau einer Woche
besonders viele Israelis ermordet wurden
als Geisel verschleppt wurden haben
inzwischen Soldaten Stellung bezogen von
dort patroulieren Sie in diesem
Niemandsland vor dem Gasastreifen und
versuchen weitere Infiltrationen zu
verhindern es gab auch Kommandoaktionen
offenbar erste
Aufklärungsversuche im Gebiet direkt am
Zaun in Gaza und der Generalstab hat der
klärt das Land sei bereit zu einer
großen Offensive zur Luft zu Wasser und
an Land das einzige was dieser Offensive
am Boden offenbar noch entgegensteht ist
die Frage der Evakuierung die kommt eben
nicht voran
und das liegt nicht zuletzt auch an der
herast die versucht diese Evakuierung
mit falschen Information offenbar mit
konkreten Straßenblockaden zu verhindern
also eines ist klar Israel wird bei
seiner Bodenoffensive nicht auf einen
menschenleeres Gaza City treffen sondern
zwischen den hamaskämpfern auch auf
viele sehr viele Zivilisten ja genau wie
wie schwierig wird diese Offensive
werden gegen eine Terrororganisation wie
die Hamas der die zivilen Opfer ja egal
sind das wird außerordgentlich heikel
ein Balanceakt
von dem Israel eigentlich nur auf eine
Seite kippen kann und verlieren kann
denn die Hamas wird auf jeden Fall äh
quasi eine ganze Stadt als menschlichen
Schutzschild benutzen und militärisch
kann man wenn man davorgeht eigentlich
dann letztendlich keine Rücksicht auf
die Zivilbevölkerung nehmen israel kann
n hoffen das bei Beginn der Kämpfe und
ich gehe davon aus dass der
Bodenoffensive noch einmal ein
intensives Bombardement von Gaza City
vorausgehen wird Israel kann nur hoffen
dass bei Beginn der wirklichen Offensive
noch ein mal wirklich viele Menschen die
Stadt verlassen werden danke Michael
auch heute Abend aus Israel vielen Dank
dorthin nur eine Autostunde von Gaza
entfernt liegt das Westjordanland ein
zweites Gebiet in dem fast drei
Millionen Palästinenser leben aber auch
mindestens eine halbe Million
israelischer Siedler zwischen diesen
beiden Gruppen kam es in den letzten
Monat zu immer heftigeren Zusammenstößen
und von dort im Westjordanland in
ramalla ist uns jetzt unsere
Korrespondentin Katrin Eigendorf
zugeschaltet Katrin wie ist die Stimmung
dort wie schauen die Palästinenser im
Westjordanland auf den Terror der Hamas
und die Lage in
Gaza ja ich habe heute hier den ganzen
Tag mit Menschen gesprochen und es eine
Mischung aus Wut und großer Sorge die
ich hier erlebt habe und auch
Hilflosigkeit
unglaublich viele Menschen hier haben
Verwandte haben Familie aber auch
Freunde in Gase sah manche kommen selbst
aus Gaza und sind hierhin umgesiedelt
weil ihnen die Situation zu angespannt
war vor Jahren schon und sie sind
praktisch den ganzen Tag über soziale
Medien aber auch über Handy soweit das
möglich ist mit den Menschen dort
verbunden verfolgen was passiert ich
habe heute mit einer frauenaktivistin
gesprochen die im Kontakt ist mit sehr
viel Frauen im Gazastreifen die aber
auch selber ihre ganze Familie zwei
Schwestern ihre Eltern dort hat und sie
sagt sie sei total hilflos und sie
könnne das gar nicht mehr mit ansehen
sie hätte den ganzen Tag gestern weint
viele Menschen sagen uns dass sie gar
nicht in der Lage sein über das zu reden
mit uns weil sie einfach die Tränen gar
nicht zurückhalten können die
Perspektive hier auf das was geschehen
ist ist allerdings eine ganz andere alle
selbst die Intellektuellen hier in
ramala machen Israel für das
verantwortlich was hier passiert ist
keiner kritisiert die Hamas für das was
geschehen ist also unsere Perspektive
dass die Hamas hier die
Zivilbevölkerung bewusst nutzt für ihren
Kampf das ist nicht die Perspektive der
palästinens in ramalla sie sagen das
alles ist eine Konsequenz der
israelischen Besatzungspolitik und erst
wenn die endet wird auch dieser Krieg
wird dieser Kampf enden können und wie
groß ist dann die Gefahr dass jetzt auch
vom Westjordanland aus neue Unruhen
ausgehen könnten für
Israel ja die wirklich brenzlige Lage
war ja eigentlich vor diesem 7 Oktober
hier im Westjordanland es hat ja hier
große Aufstände gegeben in Genien es hat
immer wieder hier auch Protest gegeben
die Lage hier war sehr schwierig und das
man kann schon fast von einem Pulverfass
sprechen dafür ist die Lage hier
erstaunlich ruhig wir waren gestern in
Jerusalem zum Freitagsgebet in der
großen alaxa Moschee die weitgehend
abgesperrt war da hatte man damit
gerechnet dass es dort Aufstände gibt
und wirklich zusammenstößt es ist total
ruhig geblieben es ist auch heute hier
in ramala sehr ruhig geblieben es hat
gestern hier auch eine Protestkundgebung
gegeben die friedlich geblieben ist aber
das Westjordanland ist ein Pulverfass
hier leben fast eine halbe Millionen
israelischer Siedler die Menschen können
sich hier nicht frei bewegen die großen
Checkpoints sind geschlossen die
Menschen können hier auch teilweise gar
nicht mehr raus und hier kann jederzeit
der Funke überspringen es wird morgen
hier auch eine große Demonstration geben
vor der deutschen Vertretung in ramalla
weil die Menschen hier sagen die
deutschen machen eine völlig falsche
Politik sie sehen uns Palästinenser
nicht sondern sie stehen nur an Israels
Seite und das wird hier sehr kritisch
gesehen und weil die Palästinenser
wollen hier dagegen
protestieren ich vermag das nicht
einzuschätzen im Moment sieht es so aus
als ob es ruhig bleiben wird aber ich
glaube da kann man auf dauern nicht
drauf bauen danke Katrin für diese
Eindrücke aus ramala Katrin Eigendorf
war das aus dem Westjordanland und hier
geht's weiter mit den Nachrichten und
Hanna Zimmermann und die beginnen mit
dem Krieg in der Ukraine der ja durch
den Israel Konflikt etwas aus dem Fokus
geraten ist die Ukraine hat erneut
massive russische Angriffe auf die Stadt
Diek im Osten des Landes gemeldet
Russland soll zusätzliche Kräfte in dem
Gebiet um die Industriestadt
zusammengezogen haben Kiev sieht die
Stadt in der Region donjetk als
strategisch wichtig an bereits seit
mehreren Tagen versucht das russische
Militär den Ort einzukesseln und vom
Nachschub
abzuschneiden nach der tödlichen
Messerattacke eines mutmaßlichen
Islamisten an einer Schule in
Nordfrankreich hat die französische
Regierung angekündigt landesweit bis zu
sie 000 Soldaten zu mobilisieren gestern
war bereits die höchste Terrorwarnstufe
ausgerufen worden heute wurde dann wegen
einer Bombendrohung der Louvre in Paris
geräumt und geschlossen gleiches gilt
für das Schloss
Wersi in Australien ist ein Referendum
mit dem der indigenen Bevölkerung mehr
politisches Mitspracherecht eingeräumt
werden sollte klar gescheitert konkret
ging es um die Bildung eines indigenen
Gremiums das das Parlament bei Themen
beraten sollte die die Ureinwohner
direkt betreffen dazu wäre eine
Verfassungsänderung nötig
gewesen in die Debatte um die Deutschen
asylregeln ist Bewegung gekommen und
zwar in Richtung Verschärfung 16
Länderchefs und Chefinnen der
Bundeskanzler und CDU Oppositionsführer
März waren sich gestern einig dass die
Zahlen der ankommenden Flüchtlinge
verringert werden müssen Olaf Scholz hat
da allerdings noch ein kleines Problem
der grüne Koalitionspartner nämlich
wehrt sich gegen härtere abschieberegeln
und Sachleistungen statt Bargeld alle
grünen nein auch hier dreht sich die
Stimmung wie janfederik Fischer und Eva
Schiller auf dem Landesparteitag der
Grünen in BadenWürttemberg beobachtet
haben bloß nicht zu grün wirken wenn die
Blasmusik spielt Termine auf dem Land
sind für die Grünen Abgeordnete nesche
erikli zunehmend ein Spießrutenlauf sie
ist eine der Stimme önigen von
badenwürtembergs grünen sehr gut dann
essen wir jetzt mal ochsenfetzen ja aber
seit das Thema Migration den Diskurs
dominiert ist grün gerade auf dem Land
zum Reizwort geworden mein mein nach
brauchen die grün sich nicht wundern
wenn die umfrageerte runtergehen wir
werden nicht alle aufnehmen können die
die zu uns kommen wollen wenn ich wie
gesagt in die nächsten 10 20 Jahre denke
wird es nicht möglich
sein Stimmungsumschwung ist im Moment
nicht anzukommen heißt für nesche erikli
mitschwenken Mehrheit möchte dass die
Migration begrenzt wird und wir müssen
da als Regierungspartei in
badenwürtemberg schauen dass wir auch
den ansprüchenende Menschen gerecht
werden und das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass man immer andere Politik wollte
oder irgendwas aufgibt so sieht das auch
der grünkonservative Ministerpräsident
was die Asylpolitik angeht er gerade die
CDU Linie übernommen muss das nur noch
seinen Parteimitgliedern verklickern
gretchmann versucht sich als Vorreiter
für eine schärfere grüne
Flüchtlingspolitik wenn wir im Namen der
Humanität die Aufnahmebereitschaft der
Gesellschaft auf Dauer massiv
überfordern dann werden wir die
Akzeptanz der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
verlieren die aktuelle Krise hat die
Wucht unser demokratisches Gemeinwesen
zu
erschüttern in Bayern und Hessen für ihn
wegruf letzte Umfragen alarmierend für
die Grünen die CDU vorbeigezogen die AFD
liegt in badenwürtemberg bei 20% und so
bemüht sich auch der aus Berlin
angereiste bundesbesuch um Rückendeckung
wir werden Steuern müssen wir werden
organisieren müssen und wir werden
deutlich mehr Ordnung reinbringen müssen
Grenzkontrollen konsequenter abschieben
Bezahlkarte für geflüchtete bislang Noos
für viele grüne
ich steh kritisch dazu ich denke wir
müssen einfach auf unsere Werte achten
von der Parteispitze for ich dass sie da
den Kurs korrigiert und wir als Grüne
weiter zu unserer DNA stehen die heißt
wir sind für eine menschliche
Asylpolitik da ist Widerspruch vor allem
von jungen aber die Mehrheit steht wie
nesche erikli hinter kretschmannskurs
weil seine machtbewussten grünen eines
fürchten dass das Thema Migration sie in
die Nische
zurückkatapultiert und jetzt die
Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die lauten
8 10 22 29 31 35 Superzahl 7 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr fehlen noch die wechselhaften
Wetteraussichten be einem Mix aus Sonne
und zahlreichen Wolken gibt es morgen im
Norden und Südosten auch Schauer und
Gewitter es wird ein lebhafter an der
Küste auch stürmischer Wind die
Temperatur erreicht 7 bis 15° in den
nächsten Tagen gibt es wieder mehr Sonne
und nur wenige Schauer im Norden mit 8
bis 15° bleibt es aber deutlich kühler
als
zuletzt und das war's für uns heute
morgen sind wir wieder für Sie da und
dann wird sich auch Christian Sievers
live aus Tel Aviv melden und immer auf
dem Laufenden bleiben Sie online bei ZF
heute wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend
tschüss
ه